thank you very much members of The
Academy first I have to thank my father
my father my dad my father and my dad
I'm grateful that I was raised by an
extraordinary man the man who uh when I
said I wanted to be an actor he said
wonderful just have a backup profession
like welding
thank you to my dad for everything he
taught me for his support for showing me
the world when you give me this award
you honor my father Paul Sorvino who has
taught me everything I know about acting
I mean my dad didn't get to see me do
any of this but I think he's looking
down on me right now to you Dad you
taught me what it means to be a man
thank you for teaching me how to Soldier
through tough situations dad
I learned so much from you all those
days of listening to Sly and the Family
Stone and Curtis Mayfield and Marvin
Gaye they really paid off so thank you
Dad to my father I love you more than
anything in the world dad you're the
greatest thank you for showing me that
there is honor in looking back and
respecting the past this is for my dad
he is so proud of me not because
this
my dad
and my dad you're a great actor but
you're a better father
foreign
my dad
I well you know Dad whistle or something
because then I'll know where you are
yeah
my father who fell in love with movies
because he needed to escape the world
and thus pass that love of movies onto
me dad I love you my dad I miss you and
thank you thanks Dad thanks Dad Dad we
did this is for my father thank you very
much